joining me now dan bongino host of
unfiltered on saturday nights at 10 p.m
on the fox news channel and my friend
dan thanks so much for being here
misinformation pete covid this moment i
mean this week has been incredibly
revealing as we start to unravel the
extent to which
they're utilizing covid and then also
working in concert
with private social media companies to
take a look at what we're doing yeah
pete listen
this is deadly serious and i'm glad to
the tone of your monologue was right
we've crossed the red line here
the government you know we have a bill
of rights right it's a document of
almost negativities i don't mean that in
a qualitative judgment way i mean the
bill of rights says what the government
can't do to you uh they can't infringe
on your right to self-protection
your second amendment rights your right
to assemble your right to speech they
can't establish a religion right
it says what the government can't do so
what the government can't do is infringe
on your free speech except in very
limited circumstances
pete what they also can't do is if they
want to crush your free speech because
they don't like your opinion on the
vaccine
or your opinion on covet lockdowns is
they can't deputize another one
and say go forth to love and serve and
do what we can't do
they are acting then as a de facto
government themselves
there is a litany of judicial precedent
for this i'm not a lawyer i didn't stay
at a holiday inn express last night i'm
not pretending to me
but i'm not an idiot either i do my
homework and i read
it is clearly obvious that gen saki and
one more thing
that gen saki's trying to deputize
through joe biden on other people
trying to deputize people to do what
they can't do and they admitted to
having a list
they admitted when peter ducey cornered
her she backed down
that's the thing they're not hiding it
they're saying it in the open the white
house is saying we're working with
facebook and other sites should ban
facebook also put out a statement today
saying yes we're working with the white
house we banned all of these people
so before it was you know we're just
conspiracy theorists wondering whether
there's
this this hand-in-glove relationship
what assurances do we have at all and i
i mentioned this in the monologue
that this doesn't turn into something a
part of the campaign candidates are
saying misinformation they can't be
allowed to speak
oh there's no assurances at all i mean
believe me if you're getting any sense
of optimism from me then i've
i've screwed this interview up i'm not
and here's the problem
where are the republicans in dc listen
guys i'm sorry get off your asses what
are you doing
i know we have a couple that are doing
so i don't want to stigmatize the whole
group
but what the hell are you doing this is
the single most important political
issue of our time
literally the ability to speak in the
public public square what's the point of
arguing tax rates
if you can't argue because you've been
banned from the new public square social
media
if you're not running on this in the
2022 election and in 2024
as your number one issue please exit
stage left
you're not the appropriate candidate you
have no idea the scope of the problem
can you imagine by the way if
republicans were what bigger topic is
misinformation out there again about by
guns right can you imagine if us
saying we want leftists banned from the
internet because they lie about guns in
the second amendment all the time
the media would be in an uproar right
absolutely you know another thing the
media was an uproar up about dan was
your information is being spread too
much on facebook i don't know if you saw
this story but proud tango who's owned
by facebook
was effectively shut down from doing
what they're doing by facebook because
executives were so embarrassed by the
fact that if you look at that list on
the right
that's from 2021 of april that's dan
bongino and ben shapiro
only on the top 10 top performing links
by us facebook pages in the last 24
hours
they're embarrassed by that dan they're
not a platform they're saying we have to
get rid of and minim
this is already after we know shadow
bannings
and and they're they're they're the
algorithms are suppressing what you're
talking about
already so you you sort of answered the
key question
republicans i can think of maybe one or
two senators that are truly concerned
about this otherwise they're asleep at
the wheel
yeah you know i watched your show last
night i was actually going to text you
during the break but i didn't want to
bother you i watched you talking about
my
facebook page let me give you a little
scoop i've only really discussed in my
podcast but not on the air because no
one's asked me up until now
other than you there's a war going on
from my facebook page behind the scenes
they hit us every single day with an
army of bot
fact checkers who check who fact check
every single comma
and period we have and if here's the
trick they use
if we say something and let's say a few
days later the information changes but
it was accurate the day we said it
this army of lead stories and gannette
fact checkers
assault my page in an attempt to limit
its reach if you had any idea i could
spend an hour
talking to you i have to pay someone a
substantial amount of money
almost full time to battle against
facebook
and the fact checkers they're not
checking facts pete they're checking my
opinions and every time we call them out
we pretty much win but i'm paying a guy
a lot of money
full time just to try and keep my show
basically on the air on facebook so
people can see it
how far behind the eight ball are
conservatives freedom lovers republicans
when it comes to 22 and 24. i know
there's an expectation
that 22 should be a midterm wave but
when you look at the weight of what
they're willing to do what they've
already done we touched on 2020 a little
bit
how far behind are we you know i think
we are because i don't think we have a
message problem i think we have a
messaging problem pete
you know i think we have to figure out
as conservatives what exactly we're
conserving
you know you know listen i was a big and
i still am a free trader i believe in
liberty and all these things
but let's be honest if we can't preserve
free speech in the open public square
social media then what the hell's the
point of conservatism the old 1970s
talking points aren't working anymore
if conservatism isn't about conserving
freedom and the ability to speak freely
in a free country
then seriously don't run you have no
idea what you're talking about
the world has changed and this party has
to change too we have to actually
conserve stuff
that's the whole idea of conservatism
and fighting for liberty and freedom
well and you're doing your part by
creating an ecosystem where freedom
lovers can actually go
if they're banned or pushed off
elsewhere you you you do what you say
yeah absolutely do something you're
exactly right dan bongino thank you so
much and congrats on the great show
thanks
appreciate it thanks hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else